masqué vous l'amérique ce même conseil
sur toutes les lèvres depuis des mois
mais une campagne de vaccination
américaine qui prend un nouveau tournant
le souhait de la nouvelle administration
américaine vacciner la majorité de la
population d'ici juillet prochain
un objectif ambitieux qui nécessite des
approvisionnements doses de vaccins
supplémentaires
[Musique]
cet après midi nous avons signé les
contrats pour 100 millions
supplémentaires de vaccins moderna et
100 millions de vaccins pfizer nous
avons également pu avancer la date de
livraison de 200 millions de vaccins
supplémentaires à fin juillet plus tôt
que ce que nous avions prévu une
campagne de vaccination donc qui
s'accélère alors qu'elle a peiné à
démarrer en décembre dernier nouvel axe
de la stratégie buy dun distribuer des
doses de vaccins dans quarante mille
pharmacies du pays ce vendredi déjà un
million de doses sont disponibles dans
six mille 500 pharmacies
les américains peuvent d'ores et déjà
s'y rendre pour recevoir leur première
dose
depuis trois semaines les états unis ont
augmenté de 30% les livraisons
hebdomadaires de vaccins une stratégie
vaccinale dont se félicite le nouveau
président américain
lorsque j'ai pris mes fonctions et à
tout juste trois semaines ce pays
n'avait pas de plan ni de vaccins
suffisant 1002 personnes pour vacciner
les américains tous les américains à
tout moment 2021
en trois semaines travaillant 24 heures
sur 24 avec des gens des gens qui se
tiennent derrière moi devant moi nous
avons maintenant acheter suffisamment de
vaccins pour vacciner tous les
américains
et maintenant nous nous efforçons de
mettre ces vaccins dans le bras de
millions de personnes en trois semaines
seulement des pharmacies mise à
contribution mais également des nouveaux
sites de vaccination et une campagne
étendu aux personnes défavorisées comme
les sans abri la pleine saison vaccinale
devraient débuter en avril alors que les
hospitalisations et le nombre de décès
sont en baisse constante depuis le pic
du 8 janvier mais les autorités
sanitaires craignent tout de même
l'émergence des différents variant autre
ombre au tableau la distribution des
doses effectué en fonction de la taille
des états est pointée du doigt en
californie état le plus endeuillé du
pays
cinq sites de vaccination ont dû
armer leurs portes faute de stocks